- I'm really delighted today
to introduce Ting Hui Lau
who is a newly appointed
Assistant Professor
of Anthropology at Yale-NUS College.
And I consider Ting to be
a friend and colleague.
I got to know Ting a
little bit during my year,
the tail end of my year in Singapore
when I was teaching as
visiting faculty at Yale-NUS,
before she had started her position there.
And so I'm really excited to know
that she's taking up the position there
because I think she's
gonna do important things
to complement the already strong
anthropology department there.
She recently received her PhD
in Anthropology from Cornell,
and she is already in
the process of finalizing
a book manuscript entitled,
Wounds of Progress Colonial Development
and the Politics of Affliction
on the China-Myanmar Border.
And the dissertation fieldwork
which informs the book
is built on a decade of engagement
and two years of continuous field work
with Lisu subsistence farmers.
And Ting has earned a reputation
in Southeast Asian studies
for her tenacity as a field worker
in notoriously difficult
field environment.
Colleagues I know from Cornell
and others who know about her work
constantly rave about the
importance of her project,
which rethinks the violent colonial
dimensions of development,
which in this area, instead of
delivering poverty reduction
has inadvertently perpetuated
high rates of violence,
alcoholism, disease and mental illness,
which are interpreted by the Lisu's forms
of haunting, curses in demon madness.
Really important and fascinating work
by a really important rising new scholar
in Southeast Asian Studies.
So please join me in welcoming Ting
for the talk today entitled,
Conjuring Spirits:
The Melancholic Play of
Alcohol Drinking Lisu Men
on The China-Myanmar Border.
- Good afternoon, everyone.
And thank you so much, Eric,
for the very kind introduction
and thank you everybody for being here.
It's such a great honor to
have a chance to share my work
with the Southeast Asian
Studies Community in Yale.
And I'm really extremely
grateful for the opportunity.
Today, I will be sharing
a chapter from my book
in Progress, Means of Progress,
Colonial Development and
The Politics of Affliction.
The book examines development
and affliction among indigenous Lisu men
in the Nu River Valley on
the China-Myanmar border.
Following a group of Lisu
men in their struggle
with chronic pain, alcoholism and madness,
I examined the social and political forces
that give rise to these afflictions
as well as the ways that
Lisu regenerate from them.
The chapter I will be talking about today,
focuses on alcohol drinking
and what leads to term, alcohol madness.
(mumbles)
Do you see my next slide?
Alcohol drinking gatherings are common
across these two villages
in the Nu River Valley.
These gatherings last between
a few hours and a week
during which the men do
not work and hardly eat,
spending their nights and days drinking,
role-playing, telling
stories, and singing.
They descend into alcohol madness.
When thus possessed,
the men are no longer
authors of their own words,
but speak on behalf of the spirits, Ni.
Straddling the space between
the living and the dead,
the alcohol mad men haunt villagers
with their (mumbles) laughter,
maniacal speeches, and uncanny cries
for the lost souls of forgotten ancestors.
This paper examines alcohol drinking
as a form of melancholic play
through which non-Christian Lisu men,
refuse indigenous cultural erasure
and the Chinese development
and Christian missionization.
Lisu in the Valley,
have long had to grapple
with the dual colonial forces
of Christian missionization
and Chinese State encroachment.
Christianity was introduced
by foreign missionaries
in the early 20th Century
or Chinese State encroachment
has been ongoing for centuries,
accelerating since the 1950s.
Both these ideologies of progress
consider indigenous Lisu ritual practices,
such as alcohol drinking,
as backward and uncivilized.
These propagandas (mumbles)
a static image of the Lisu
and contribute to Lisu
cultural loss and dignity loss.
I show how non-Christian
alcohol drinking men
refused such ideologies.
Gathering to drink and play,
the men infuse melancholia
with play humor and laughter
and keep supposedly bygone practices alive
through the partial revitalization
of old alcohol drinking rituals.
This analysis joins scholar
limitizing Eurocentric ideas
about melancholia as pathological.
So the conventional idea,
the conventional Freudian idea,
that melancholia is a incomplete grief,
grief that is unhealthy
because the mourning
can never be concluded.
Situating Lisu experiences of loss
in relation to historical colonialism,
my analysis shows how the pathology lies
not in Lisu relationships with loss,
but in the colonial
processes undergirding loss.
In this context,
melancholia is not a passive
inability to embrace change,
but an active unwillingness to move on.
The talk is organized into four parts.
I will begin with a brief introduction
of the colonial dynamics
animating the ethnographic
context in which I work.
Next, I discuss alcohol
within the triad of Lisu
indigenous cultural paradigms,
Christianity and Chinese development
following which I delve into a night
of drinking and melancholic play
with a group of non-Christian
alcohol drinking men.
And finally, I close this talk
with a brief discussion
on listening to affliction
and the implications of
such forms of listening
for public health interventions.
So I'm gonna begin with a brief discussion
on the ethnographic
context to set the scene.
The Lisu are an indigenous
people living dispersed
across the Highlands of
mainland Southeast Asia,
along the borders of China,
Myanmar, Thailand, and India.
My ethnography focuses on the
Lisu, in the Nu River Valley
on the China-Myanmar border.
As you can see the river
follows the blue line there.
The Valley is formally within the borders
of the Chinese State,
but geographically located
in the Highlands of
mainland Southeast Asia,
the region referred to by
some scholars as Zomia.
Scholars have defined Zomia
as a vast (mumbles) zone
where communities have historically fled
to escape state rule.
The Lisu are one of the
many indigenous communities
residing in this trans border terrain.
The Nu River Valley
is a traditional territory
of many indigenous peoples
with the Lisu constituting one
of the largest communities.
Like many countries in Asia,
China does not recognize the existence
of indigenous groups within its borders.
The Lisu are classified
by the Chinese communist government,
as one of the officially
recognized 55 ethnic minorities.
But the Lisu experience
of cultural erasure
and political marginalization,
under Chinese assimilationist,
ethnic policies,
resonates with the struggles
of indigenous communities elsewhere.
As (mumbles) argue,
it is the oppositional
please base existence
along with the consciousness
of being in struggle
against the dispossessing
and demeaning fact of
colonization by foreign peoples
that fundamentally
distinguishes indigenous peoples
from other peoples of the world.
This article connects the Lisu struggle
with the experiences of
indigenous communities elsewhere
to relativize Chinese
ethnic classifications,
to underscore the psychic
and cultural experience
of being Lisu.
Like other indigenous communities
residing in this trans
border Highland region,
the Lisu wrestle with
multiple colonial forces,
including state civilizational projects,
economic development and
religious missionization.
These processes have estranged Lisu
from the traditional ritual practices
which they call practices
of the earlier days.
(speaking foreign language)
These include making offerings
to the spirits, (mumbles)
soul calling (mumbles)
spirit dancing, (mumbles)
and sorcery, (mumbles) and
reassemble those carried out
by other indigenous
communities in the region.
When I began my dissertation
fieldwork in 2015,
I came eager to learn
about Lisu ritual life,
but many of my Lisu interlocutors
treated my questions
about rituals as inquiries about the past.
They explained that these rituals,
which often involved alcohol
were pre-Christian practices
that were no longer being followed.
As with many Christianized
indigenous communities,
the introduction of Christianity
effectively divided history
into two distinct parts;
pre Christianity and post Christianity.
Today, the majority of
the Lisu in the Valley
practice indigenized
protestant Christianity.
All Christian activities
must be endorsed by the central church,
which is part of the state sanction,
Three Self Protesting Church.
Although some Lisu practice alternative
non-state sanctioned
forms of Christianity,
they are actively persecuted
by the Chinese communist party
and have become a minority.
Despite government's surveillance
of Christian activities,
many Christian Lisu continue
to relate to Christianity
as something beyond
full government control.
Christianity remains an
important source of power,
healing and resistance against
Chinese state (mumbles)
But dominantly Lisu Christian ideology
also have many structural parallels
with Chinese ideologies of development
including a linear notion
of time and progress.
Christian needs to reproduce
Chinese domination in many ways,
for example, Lisu Christians,
a lineal conception of time and progress,
denigrate non-Christians as
primitive demon worshipers.
Although many Lisu Christian practices
are similar to traditional rituals,
Christian Lisu work hard
to differentiate themselves
from non-Christians.
Lisu Christianity
forbids smoking, gambling
telling non-Christian once
upon a time origin stories
(mumbles) and above all drinking alcohol.
Many Christian Lisu hesitate
even to share memories
of traditional cosmologies and rituals
for fear of being labeled unfaithful
and being ostracized by
the Christian community.
Certainly, Christian Lisu
have a complex and contextual relationship
with non-Christian Lisu
practices and people,
but a defining characteristic
of many Christian Lisu
is the constant cultural work
they do to distance themselves
from their supposedly simple
non-Christian Lisu past.
The rise of Christianity has occurred
alongside rapid Chinese development.
Like many ethnic communities
and contemporary China,
Lisu have negotiated with
the civilizing mission
of encroaching Chinese
state power for centuries.
In the communist era,
rapid Chinese development
has further upended the ways
of life of the Lisu and other minorities
with accelerating
upheaval since the 2000s.
Like Christianity, Chinese
development discourses
deny the (mumbles) of Lisu
indigenous life worlds.
While Christianity is recognized
by many Lisu and Chinese people
as a modern foreign religion,
Lisu indigenous ritual practices
are labeled as primitive.
Many Lisu have internalized
this ideology of contempt.
Through residential schooling,
factory work and urbanization,
Lisu have being recruited
into the Chinese state bureaucracy,
market economy and Han majority society.
These assimilationist programs
have gained intensity in recent years.
Since 2011, Chinese ethnic policies
have adopted a fiercer
assimilationist stance
towards its ethnic minority populations.
In this context,
the arenas in which minority
ways of life can be recognized,
I've narrowed to the domains of tourism
or ethnological research,
that is, Lisu traditional practices
are being petrified into static objects
for tourists and research consumption.
Lisu are thus simultaneously
being assimilated
into the dominant Chinese society
and being objectified into artifacts.
So my next section talks about alcohol
and how alcohol works within this context.
I titled this The Gift of Alcohol
and it's the gift from the ancestors.
Alcohol lies at the center
of the triadic relationship
between these two indigenous
cultural paradigms,
Christianity, and Chinese development.
Once a sacred item used
during important ritual,
alcohol was respected as a
powerful substance by the Lisu.
Traditionally, among many Lisu,
alcohol was seen as a
gift from the spirits,
a powerful medium that
connects humans to non-humans
and transform sadness to joy.
Accepting the gift of
alcohol, binds the Lisu person
to a reciprocal relationship
with the spirits.
Lisu sorceress, (mumbles)
were people who knew how to
wheel the power of alcohol
to communicate with spirits.
My Lisu interlocutors described
how sorceress used alcohol
as means to summon the spirits.
With the aid of the assembled spirits,
these sorceress (mumbles)
deserving punishment,
and sort justice for
those who were wronged.
Alcohol was used in healing
rituals, for example,
it was also using feeling
if a soul left the body after
a frightening encounter,
skillful sorceress could
sometimes reunite the lost souls
with their host bodies through
alcohol mediated rituals.
But for those who were less skillful,
alcohol could be overpowering,
it could deceive.
If a person was unable to control
the voices of the spirits,
alcohol consumption can lead
to temporary or permanent
madness (mumbles)
or spirit induce epilepsy. (mumbles)
Out of respect for the powerful spirits,
Lisu made offerings of alcohol
and meat to the spirits,
to honor their reciprocal ties.
But as indigenous Lisu ritual paradigms
and practices eroded with
conversion to Christianity,
and the Chinese development,
so did the status of alcohol.
The sacred relationship with alcohol
has changed significantly
with development and
conversion to Christianity.
Alcohol is now rejected by Christians
as a poison that tempts and contaminates.
The (mumbles) speech of drunk men,
are the words of the demons within them
rather than the human animating the body.
The alcohol drinkers
are no longer seen as skillful sorcerers,
but as useless drunkards
or worse yet Satan's underlings.
Christian Lisu instead
accept another kind of gift,
(mumbles) the gift of eternal life,
(mumbles) from God, (mumbles)
Embracing God's grace,
they seek to break away
from their supposedly demonic
past which alcohol recalls.
Similarly, Chinese development discourses
often portray minority
people, like the Lisu,
as people who drink too
much and who are ungrateful.
Under Chinese and Christian
ideologies of progress,
alcohol drinking Lisu are referred
as primitive or damaged people
and their spirits and the
spirits they mingle with
are branded as demonic
or dismissed as superstitious delusions.
Hypocritically, the Han majority
sees mainstream drinking and
Han society as masculine,
violent, productive and civilized.
These days, alcohol
drinking Lisu men and women
are stigmatized by Christian
and Chinese discourses
that often portrayed them as primitive,
sexually loose, poor, smelly and dirty.
These discourses are gendered.
Although many Lisu women drink,
men are usually the heavy drinkers.
Alcohol drinking men, (mumbles)
has become a general term
of the used derogatorily.
I'm very happy to talk more
about the gender dynamics in the Q and A.
This talk focuses, and my book in Progress
generally focuses on men,
but I actually spent most
of my time with women.
But contrary to popular
and Christian beliefs,
alcohol dependency and
alcohol related violence
emerged relatively recently.
Traditionally Lisu
alcohol is made from maize
because maize is an important staple food
for humans and animals.
In former times only social elites
with an abundance of maize
had the resources to make alcohol.
The expansion of commercial alcohol
transform Lisu relationships with it,
As commercial beer and liquor
became widely and cheaply
available in stores
and real estate commissaries
in the 1980s and 1990s,
addiction has become
more common among Lisu.
The collapse of indigenous
Lisu cultural practices
and the Christianization
and Chinese development
has also disrupted the ritual context
that provides structure for
Lisu drinking activities.
The non-Christian,
alcohol drinking men's
attachment to alcohol
takes place within this
complex historical landscape.
By the time I visited Goza,
most elders in the village
identified as Christians.
The alcohol drinking men,
whom I spent time with
were the few elders in the village
who remained non-Christians.
There were about a dozen of them,
a handful or particularly close.
Uncle Zoda and his best
friend, uncle Mobi,
uncle Sapo, and his two brothers,
uncle Sathi and uncle Saki
and the younger uncle Yosa and uncle Aki.
So following Lisu ethical
and using Lisu kinship terms
such as uncle (mumbles)
to index intergenerational respect,
we got lots of formal kinship ties.
They proudly proclaim themselves
to be alcohol drinking men
except for a couple of their wives.
Most of the women in the
village were Christians.
Although Christian villagers
were generally on amicable terms
with the non-Christian elders,
the tension between the
groups were obvious.
During my fieldwork,
these men drank regularly
some like uncle Zoda and uncle Mobi,
drank as often and as much as they could,
others drank frequently,
but with more control.
Uncle Sapo and his brothers,
uncle Sathi and uncle Saki, for example,
who usually brings drink once
or twice a month for several days,
and then spend the rest of
the month relatively sober.
This cyclical binge drinking resemble
the old drinking pattern
the auntie Yona said
was common in the earlier days
when men used to drink
for big celebrations
or for important rituals.
The habits of the men were partly shaped
by their own personal
histories and circumstances,
for example, uncle Zoda's
compulsive drinking
resulted in part from the
chronic pain he suffered
from having endured forced sterilization
under China's birth planning
policy in the 1990s.
His sons frequent ventures
to drink away from home with his friends
was intern probably related
to his father's rowdy
drinking gatherings at home
which drove the son to find
other venues of release.
In general, older drinkers
tended to enjoy liquor
while younger drinkers, like
uncle Zoda's son, liked beer,
but older young, all
these two alcohol drinkers
I met in Goza and beyond
preferred homemade liquor and beer.
During my stay in (mumbles),
I lived with uncle Zoda and auntie Yona
who had two children,
a son and a daughter.
Uncle Zoda and his son were not Christian.
Auntie Yona on the other
hand was a devout Christian.
Their daughter, Nana was
a Christian by default
because of her gender and
because of her mother's faith.
Nana was my classmate
and my Lisu language
tutor in Minzu University
in the provincial capital of Kunming
where I was enrolled as
a Lisu language student.
Like many younger members of the village,
Nana and her brother were usually away.
Nana was attending university
and her brother was working in
the factories in the cities.
Their absence meant that...
Until the fields planted maize,
weeded the grounds,
scavenged for pig feed
and cut firewood alongside auntie Yona.
Through these everyday work activities,
auntie Yona taught me Lisu.
As I gained (mumbles) in Lisu,
I conducted most of my research
in the language of my host.
Although this paper focuses on Lisu men,
I spent most of my days in
the village with Lisu women.
The women are preparing the vegetables
to sell in the marketplace the next day,
and I think this was
already midnight by then.
For many of the women,
alcohol drinking husbands
were the heaviest burden.
As the men partied through the night,
the women dealt with
everyday mundane realities,
like for example,
getting the vegetables prepared
at midnight to sell in the market there.
I did not participate in drinking alcohol,
but I was often included as an observer
and a welcome photographer.
During these rowdy gatherings,
I was frankly, often tired
from working in the fields
and I wish I could rest
instead of attending
to the men's (mumbles)
Auntie Yona now was exhausted as well.
And I always felt there
was a shared understanding
between auntie Yona and the men
as if their drinking was
also a catharsis for her.
Although she did not drink,
she joined them as they joke
and make fun of each other.
Following her example
and began to listen more
carefully to the drunken speech
of the alcohol drinking
men in (mumbles) village.
So now I'm moving on to the next section
where I'm going to be talking
about melancholic play
in the night of drinking with the men.
One ordinary wintry evening,
not long after the pigs were fed
and the chicken feed prepared,
a group of men came to visit uncle Zoda.
Heavy footsteps on the bamboo porch
alerted us to their arrival.
It was the usual (mumbles)
uncle Mobi, the man
condemned by an old curse,
uncle Sapo, the retired
sorcerer in the village,
uncle Api, the villager
afflicted with epilepsy,
uncle Yosa, the divorcee
who is captured by Burmese soldiers
and presumed dead for seven years,
and uncle Aki, the widower
whose wife went nerd.
These were uncle Zoda's blood brothers,
fellow non Christian men
who found solidarity with each other
in their shared love for
alcohol and the past.
Auntie Yona welcomed them.
She served them food,
which they declined,
and shared uncle Zoda's alcohol with them
which they eagerly accepted.
The men had gathered to celebrate
the return of uncle Aki.
Aki was the youngest of the lot
and often left the village
for long periods of
working construction jobs
in the Northern part of the County.
Actually, it was the Northern
County above the prefecture.
Passing bottle after bottle
and cup after cup of alcohol,
the men chattered, laughed,
sang and cried in joy.
"Drink alcohol!" Uncle Zoda cried,
"Let's talk and joke together,
"but no fighting, no quarreling."
Uncle Sapo, the eldest of them said.
Alcohol circulated
continuously among them.
The gathering began relatively calmly,
but rose quickly to a
crescendo of inebriated chaos,
loud laughter, howls,
reverberated through the room.
Lisu pop music videos blasted
from Zoda's television
providing the shrill accompaniment
to this carnival esque scene.
The incandescent bulb
that hung above the flashing TV
and the burning flame from the campfire
pass moving shadows around the room,
giving the strange effect
that the house was even
darker than it already was.
Excited by my camera,
the men insisted I take pictures of them,
drunk and half naked.
Zoda sharing beer with Mobi in a bowl,
Aki pretending to be a
corpse hanging from a tree,
and me pretending to share
a cigarette with Aki.
Each of these acts was
a reference to the past.
Zoda and Mobi sharing a
beer from the same bowl
resemble the cross cupping practice
that Lisu used to perform
during weddings and other celebrations.
Uncle Aki pretending to be a corpse
reminded me of the Lisu story
about the star crossed lovers
who hang themselves from a tree.
The cigarettes were new,
but they represented the traditional pipes
that Lisu used to smoke.
In their drunkenness,
the men broadcast their
skewed imaginings of the past,
the liquor mix of half
memories, false memories
and incomplete, erroneous stories
about things, people and events
that may never have actually been.
"I am a prophet!" Uncle Zoda called out
provoking much laughter among the men.
"Bring me meat!"
Many of the sorceress who
converted to Christianity
became Christian prophets. (mumbles)
Uncle enjoyed making fun
of these sorcerer prophets.
He saw them as sorcerers
trying to cheat their way
into the Christians hearts and pockets.
"Their true aim," He said,
"Was to earn as much meat as possible."
"Tell me the next lottery
number uncle." I joked with him.
Zoda took a pause
as if trying to find the
number with his mind's eye.
"I don't see them,"
(mumbles) Zoda replied,
"Come back tomorrow, if the
laughter reverberates it."
The boundaries between the
living and the undead blurred,
the more the men drank, the
closer the spirits came to them.
As the men descended into
alcohol madness, (mumbles)
Their (mumbles) speech
indicated the possible presence
of something other than human.
"Take a picture. Take a picture.
"I am a demon here to kill humans.
(speaking Lisu language)
"I am a demon here to eat humans."
Shouted an alcohol mad, uncle Mobi.
As he insisted that I take
a picture of him and Zoda.
Pretending he was holding a Lisu machete,
Mobi stood behind Zoda,
acting like a demon about
to kill an oblivious Zoda.
The alcohol mad Mobi,
ready himself to conduct
an imaginary murder.
Possessed by the spirit,
Mobi was no longer fully present.
As was common on such occasions,
the absent Mobi went to a
lasting trace of his demon self.
My Nikon camera
with its ability to capture
his absent presence,
became an object of desire.
In Zoda's house spirit
and men run (mumbles)
Like the stigmatized
men who summoned them,
the spirits were beings
denied recognition.
Formerly powerful and respected spirits,
they had turned into downtrodden,
forgotten and dismissed demons,
wronged by the circumstances
of their life and death,
wronged by the Christians
who betrayed them,
and wronged by the Chinese state
that branded them as
primitive superstitions.
The demonized spirits were unable to rest.
Identifying with these demons,
the men let the spirits
speak, allowing them
to express the shared
grievances of men and spirit.
In their drunkenness,
the men took on the dual role
of the sorceress seeking justice
and the demon wronged by others.
Rather than trying to free
themselves from the spirits,
they summoned them to the present.
Their melancholy howls
pierced the silence of the village night,
jolting their Christian neighbors awake,
making them listen to the sounds
and sorrows of banish ancestors.
As the night went on,
the men descended deeper and
deeper into alcohol madness,
hurling insults at each other.
They pruned out of tune music
and gave in decipherable speeches
about themselves and their pasts.
Among the men,
Mobi and Zoda were the
most resilient drinkers.
As everyone began to wonder home,
Mobi stayed with Zoda.
The two ate each other on to
drink more and play harder.
The next morning,
sleep deprived aunt Yona and I
found them both unconscious.
Mobi laid next to the dead
campfire on the floor,
Zoda was rolled on his bed, motionless.
In the dead of the
night, when others sleep,
the men called upon the
spirits with their alcohol.
Together, men and spirit danced, sang
and haunted the quiet orderly lives
of their Christian neighbors.
Drinking alcohol, the men's bodies
became the medium through which spirits
re-entered the world of the living.
Dancing and singing together,
spirit and men honor
their ties to each other.
The despair of loss was transfigured
into the joys of existence,
forgotten memories into living rituals
demons into ancestors,
alcohol drinking men
into powerful sorcerers
and death back into life.
Drinking is an act of togetherness.
Alcohol brought together
the alcohol drinking men in (mumbles)
as brothers with a shared commitment
to remembering lost practices
and forgotten ancestors.
Whereas the Christians in the village
sought to break away from old practices,
the alcohol drinking
men refused to move on.
Their melancholia united
them as a community
against the Christian
majority in the village.
"We are the alcohol drinking men.
"We work when we feel like working,
"stop when we feel like stopping,
"not like those people who go to church,
"they are full of superstitions."
Uncle Saki, proudly proclaimed once,
turning a typical Christian insult back
at the Christians themselves.
The men purposefully went
against those things that
Christian said and did.
Christians attended church
and did not work on Sundays.
Non-Christians had alcohol
drinking gatherings
and worked any day of
the week or not work.
Christians did not eat the blood
and internal organs of animals,
alcohol drinking men on the other hand,
praised them as delicacies.
Christians considered phrases
such as "Thank you," (mumbles)
"Forgive me," (mumbles)
and "How are you," (mumbles) polite.
Non-Christians found
these expressions phony.
The alcohol drinking uncles (mumbles)
enjoyed poking fun at the Christians.
"The best time to steal meat
"is when Christians are
saying grace before a meal,
"when they have their eyes shut
"pick your favorite pieces
of meat from the dishes.
"They won't even notice.
"And if they do, you
can just call them out
"for not praying properly."
Uncle Mobi, uncle Zoda's
best friends taught me once.
The men's witticism expanded
beyond making fun of
their Christian neighbors.
They made jokes about
cunning Han Chinese migrants;
strange foreigners,
book smart, but otherwise
stupid university students,
bewitching Burmese women,
lying Christian missionaries
and greedy Chinese communist official.
Once the government
distributed each household
some walnut cuttings to plant.
Although walnuts are lucrative,
many Lisu avoid eating them.
"Eating too much Walnut oil," they say,
"Can turn a person into an idiot."
"Si Ching Ping must like
eating a lot of walnuts,
"that's why he keeps
asking us to plant walnuts.
"No wonder he's so stupid."
Uncle Zoda said as we
planted walnut cuttings.
As the men pass alcohol around,
they reversed Chinese and
Christian discourses of gratitude.
There were no longer the ungrateful ones
for rejecting the gifts of
Christianity and development.
It was instead the Christians
who were ungrateful
having forgotten about the spirits,
having abandoned their
brothers and sisters,
and having ultimately given
up what it means to be Lisu.
Breathing new life, to
old reciprocal ties,
the men rebuilt a community from ruins,
from the ruins of loss
and reminded that fellow villagers,
Christians and non-Christians alike
that they were not yet dead.
As uncle Mobi used to defiantly yell,
"I cannot die." (mumbles)
Refusing to let go,
the men held on together to fragments
of what it means to be Lisu
outside of Christian and
Chinese civilizational frames.
So I'm now going to conclude.
Around two years after I left (mumbles)
I received a message from Nana
letting me know that
her father, uncle Zoda,
was critically ill.
His organs were failing and he was dying.
Upon receiving the news
of uncle's illness,
I prepared my return to China,
but as I was getting ready to go back,
COVID-19 hit Wuhan
and travels to China
soon became impossible.
(mumbles) village went under lockdown.
Villagers were instructed to remain
in their own homes and villages.
I called uncle Zoda one afternoon
aware that it might be
our last conversation.
"I'm still here," He
said almost cheerfully,
"Not dead yet.
"These days we cannot go anywhere.
"Even the demons cannot move.
"If demons don't move,
people can't move on either.
"I'm just hanging out, watching TV,
"sitting by the fire next to the demons,
"not dead yet."
He burst into laughter.
I laughed with him.
Zoda continued to play
in the face of death.
Melancholia once more transformed
into a half funny joke.
This talk has examined how low status
Lisu alcohol drinking men,
play with melancholy as an act of refusal.
Within communities struggling
for their cultural and spiritual survival,
like playing with melancholia
can be a mode of refusal.
As I have argued,
the alcohol drinking men's
melancholia is a refusal
because it is constituted
by a playful and willingness to let go
rather than an inability to overcome.
By the same token,
their refusal is melancholic
because it is characterized
by an attachment to things
that are supposed to be dead.
Infusing grief with play, humor and joy,
the men draw on despair, loss,
and suffering as a cultural resource
for the reconstitution of
community within, but apart
from the dominant Christian
and Chinese frames of civilization.
Ambivalently mixing sadness and joy,
tragedy and comedy,
forgetting and remembering,
the melancholic play illustrates
the complex contradictions
constituting experiences of grief
that shape intimate everyday politics.
Refusal through melancholic play,
speaks to cross-cultural experiences
of how people recuperate and regenerate
in the thrills of colonial domination.
Indigenous and minority communities
are often portrayed as damaged victims,
but there is no doubt that
these communities struggle
with great injustice and oppression.
People face suffering, not
only with anger and despair,
but also with humor and play.
Illness and afflictions
such as alcohol dependency
are symptoms of victim hood,
but they are also acts
through which people convey,
communicate and share their experiences
by attending to jokes and social histories
of men who might be considered
by public health experts as alcoholic.
I pay attention to the social commentaries
and historical memories they articulate
through their affliction.
Situating such afflictions
as alcohol dependency
in relation to these
historical structures,
reverses the disease discourse.
The pathology lies not in the sick person,
but in the social and political structures
within the illness emerge.
Within which the illness emerge.
Lisu alcohol drinking
men's melancholic refusal
provides inspiration for thinking
about how to combine dark anthropology
and the anthropology of the good.
Proponents of the anthropology of the good
critique contemporarily
anthropology's tendency
to universalize the suffering subject
which they argue is a
modern day replacement
of the savage slot.
Similarly, indigenous
scholars have proposed
a moratorium on damaged centered research
that portrays indigenous communities
as only, or mainly damaged.
But this call to suspend
damage center research
is not about denying damage
nor about turning our
attention towards only the good
rather it is a call for
an epistemological shift
in the way research is
conducted and motivated.
Activist anthropology
in which anthropologists
are directly involved in the
social movements they study,
provides an important starting point
for rethinking the theories of
change undergirding research.
Part of this epistemological shift
towards research for
change and transformation
is to recognize people as complex subjects
who shift in contradictory desires.
Desires that simultaneously
resist and reproduce power.
Lisu men's melancholic alcohol drinking
is constituted by such complex interplays
between despair and joy
and between loss and regeneration.
Their melancholia is not just
an embodiment of victim hood,
but also the grounds on
which they refuse colonialism
and celebrate their survival.
Theories of the subject
that fully recognize such
complex and contradictory desires
(mumbles) a critical foundation
for building solidarities
and for rethinking the theories of change
undergirding anthropology research.
Thank you.
Thanks, very excited about your questions.
- Thank you Ting for a fantastic talk.
So we have plenty of time
for question and answer,
but I'm mindful of people's time.
I know some people have
to leave at one sometimes
because of various time commitments.
So I'd like to ask anyone who thinks
they need to leave by one,
please ask your question first.
Otherwise, we'll just go in the order
in which I see hands.
So if you wanna say then
you need to ask first,
put it in the chat.
Otherwise we'll just go in an order.
Is there anyone who has a time commitment?
Otherwise I'll just call on El
'cause I see El has a question.
So El go ahead and ask your question
and then if anyone else needs to,
will follow up with that.
- Nice to meet you. I'm a PhD student here
in Anthropology and Environmental Studies.
I used to be at Yale NUS.
So this is great. (laughs)
So this is fascinating
and if this is a chapter,
I'm looking forward the book.
And so I'm still really excited.
And I particularly was thinking
about the ways that this is similar
or different to like
parts of Northern Thailand
where you have the Karen,
(mumbles) and the Burma as well
and how the Christian Buddhist narrative
is actually fundamentally very different.
So that was kind of interesting
for me to think through and compare it
because to the Christians in the village,
in Northern Ireland they were like, "Oh,
"we're super open to Christians.
"The Buddhists were
like the dominant people
"and it's all great."
So it was really interesting
that very clear reversal there
in terms of what I'm familiar with.
But sorry my question was about ontology
and I'm wondering how you
theorize ontology in a sense.
So in one primary sense
there's that (mumbles) and uncanny,
and then what's interesting here
is I feel like the
melancholy kind of comes
into that kind of lack of re inability
to kind of do away with repression,
so that coming back with the repression.
And it's really interesting
and also to think about
the role of the spirits
in terms of them being wrong,
but then it kind of Andrew Johnson's book
talked a lot more about ambivalent.
So here the spirit seems
to be a lot more active and and angry
as opposed to like more ambivalent
kind of relationship on the river.
Another sense of oncology
is this kind of social control.
And so this idea
about nations being built
on the zonal mass death
is something like (mumbles)
talks about in China.
And I'm wondering to what extent
you can think about ontology
as a molding kind of individual
and where you're talking
about intra-Lisu identity
but also kind of different
scales of identity
in the kind of social control there.
So I'm just wondering kind of like
how you're thinking about...
There's so much to do with the ethnography
that's coming through.
I'm just wondering like
how you're putting all
those thoughts together?
- [Ting] Thank you.
I'll just respond.
That's such a great question
and I don't know if I can answer
completely, do it justice.
So I think the way I'm
thinking about haunting
is partly that indeed there
is this desire to move away.
That we have overcome our indigenous
or our kind of either
it is the simple past
with a Christian perspective
or it is that we're moving on
from the backward at Lisu practices,
and we're trying to become modern
but that is never a complete
conversion in a sense.
So the uncanny, it is
like an uncanny reminder
that these men are living in this space.
They're staying in this space
that reminds the villagers
and the people around them
that have never really actually,
you're not really ever completely modern
and actually
the demons reside within you.
And so there's perhaps the
haunting emerges in that sense.
In the scale of...
I thought that was so interesting,
the nation built on mass death
because I think there's this a place
that is built on mass death.
And so there is that scale,
that's really helpful
for me to think through
and include in my next
iteration of this chapter
because there is that scale
of the village haunting,
the men haunting the villagers
by reminding them of the past.
But there's also the scale
in which this whole place
which is being promoted as a
tourist hotspot, as developed
because Chinese state is
developing this place.
It's modern. It's becoming
modern, there's no more poverty,
but all of that narrative
is built on so much death in the region.
Cultural death of the
men that I've described,
but also the physical death of the people
who are dying in traffic accidents,
who are dying in construction work,
who are dying in landslides,
who are dying because of
family problems and suicide
and mental health and
alcoholism and sickness,
and cancer and other kinds of new diseases
that were never there in the first place,
that have recently become for some reason
like other parts of the world,
development is correlated
with the rise of all these
noncommunicable diseases.
And so there is that level,
the level of that scale
that you're talking about
where development is
actually built on mass death.
And in a sense,
this place is haunted by that death
that is also being repressed
by the discourse of development.
And that's really helpful.
And I think there's a
third level of haunting
where I'm trying to think about
which is almost (mumbles)
get out of the question
of trying to bracket the
question of the demons
and whether I can even
understand what they're doing.
And there's a part of the chapter
that I wasn't able to
include because of time
where uncle Mobi passes away,
but he returns in the form
of dreams and spirits,
and it's almost like he continues
to refuse to die even after death.
And so there's that openness
that I'm not sure if I
want to allow for closure
to analyze what's
actually happening there.
Is uncle Mobi actually coming back
or is this like an uncanny thing,
but I think I'm trying to see how
his death actually created
this report effect.
And we generate a lot of
discourse around haunting
that I am not quite sure I should...
Maybe I should refuse to
theorize it too rigorously.
So maybe allowing the ethnography
to haunt itself (mumbles)
I guess, I don't know.
Thank you for the great question.
- [Eric] Thank you, Ting.
Does anyone a question?
I have several questions, but I'm mindful.
I wanna make sure other
people have the chance to ask
but if there's not one at the moment,
I will ask one first and
then follow up later.
So Ting this is a fantastic
talk, very interesting.
There's a lot of directions
to go that I'm interested in,
but I wanna talk a little bit
about sort of the micro politics
and spatial organization
of these places in the valley
where you were working in the villages.
I'm curious if you're
doing this kind of research
and there's such a kind
of negative stereotype
of the alcohol drinking Lisu
men among the Christian Lisu.
When you fall into a group
of men doing field work,
or families that have men of this nature,
does that end up
precluding the possibility
of working with Christians
and how does that get negotiated?
And that raised my other question,
sort of just ethnographic
description a little bit
about the Christianity in the area
and the spatial organization of villages,
are there sort of spatial arrangements
and where these men
live in a separate part
or even sort of on the outskirts outside
or anything like that,
or forms of exclusion?
In terms of the actual
Christian conversion process
are people born Christian
or did they convert?
And the reason I asked that is
because some of what you're describing,
when in America 12 step programs
and all these things
there's a lot of literature
that shows the parallel to conversion
and there's a lot of Christian
language in those processes.
And sometimes when I was listening to you,
I was thinking, "Well,
"the way in which some of the Christians
"are responding to the alcoholism,
"sounds kind of similar
to like the way a member
"of a 12 step program might speak of it."
And so that made me wonder
if some of the Christians themselves
had been former drinkers and
this kind of reaction to it
is based on these kinds of dynamics.
So there's a lot in there,
but mainly I want to
hear a little bit more
about the micro relations of
Christians and non-Christians
and also how that affected
you as a field worker.
- [Ting] Thank you, Eric.
Yeah, the micro politics
were complicated to navigate.
Actually, I think it
was the other way around
that when I first started working,
I worked a lot with Christians.
My first visit to the Nu River Valley
I was working with Christian missionaries
and I felt that during those early visits
oftentimes I was precluded
talking with non-Christians
and they were like, "Don't talk to them."
Or the Christians would move away
as I will follow the Christians.
And even though I was
actually very curious
to talk to the non-Christians.
At times I think earlier
on, I think, I was biased
by some Christian perceptions
as well often thinking,
"Oh, these people, why
don't they not drink?
I think I took a lot of my own
having to interrogate
those assumptions as well
which were the assumptions of the people
that I was working with at the beginning.
It took years to build relationships
with the Christian communities
and then work with non-Christians
and still have that trust
with the Christians,
that I'm not an alcohol drinker.
I think that was actually...
This was actually something
I was thinking today that
it was easier for me to be.
I wonder how it would have been like
if I had gone to the field
and just be really stubborn and say,
"I drink alcohol and I'm not Christian
"and I'm just going to hang
out with the non-Christians."
But I did not, that was
not my starting point.
The starting point was,
"I'll go to church,
"I'll do the rituals with you.
"I'm not Christian,
"but I will follow the steps
"and be included in your conversation
"and be willing to listen
and learn about the Bible."
And then that starting
point then allowed me,
the non-Christians allowed
me to talk to them.
But I think if it was the other way around
that if I started as a non Christian,
I'm not so sure if the
Christian communities
will be so welcome welcoming to me.
Because I started with
the Christian communities
then it was difficult to get out
into talking to the non-Christians
because there were lots of gate keeping,
but the non-Christians were welcoming
and were willing to talk and ultimately,
after a lot of kind of
negotiation, it was fine.
Although I think because I
was living in a household
where the women were Christian.
So in that sense, I had
to respect the women
and also navigate being open
to hanging out with the men,
but also respecting
auntie for wanting to...
She wanted to go to church
and to not drink alcohol with the men.
The villagers...
So all these micro politics play out
in very ritualistic ways as well.
So even though the
villagers in everyday ways,
they kind of do get along with each other,
but they don't eat Christian...
Christians don't eat the
meat of non-Christians.
So if the non-Christian had
a funeral or a family member
and the non-Christians also
had a funeral or a wedding,
the Christians cannot consume
the meat of the non-Christian.
So even though in an everyday way,
people kind of get along with each other
in the kind of structural
way or individual setting,
these boundaries are very clearly drawn.
And in the kind of backstage,
the conversations do take place
where the Christians are
critiquing the non-Christians
and then the non-Christians
like critiquing the Christians.
I think being with a
Christian friend, auntie Yona,
I think it was possible
to listen to both sides.
And so that was auntie Yona and I,
being open-minded, be with both groups
and allowing conversations
to take place in between the groups.
I can go on about the micro politics
because it also affects kind
of the village dynamics.
So the village has a
whole hierarchy system
and then the men have
their own hierarchy system.
So when the men were
conducting work parties
they will follow their own hierarchies
of who are the seniors
and the Christians will
follow some other hierarchies.
And so it's almost like they
have two different bubbles,
but intersecting.
The spatial arrangements.
Yeah, that's really interesting
'cause I did not think about it,
but in fact it is so true
that the non-Christians
tend to be living away
from the Christians, further out.
Where the non-Christians were living,
the people tend to consider
they were near haunted sites.
I did not consider that
was connected directly
to alcohol drinking,
but I think there is
some sort of connection.
The people often consider
the pathways that go
towards an non-Christians household
and there will be a haunted site,
or there's a kind of
tombs around the places
where the non-Christians reside.
But this whole arrangement
now is, I understand,
is completely changed since
I was last able to visit
because of the One Belt
One Road Initiative
which runs through the village.
And so all the villages
who are living by the roads
have had to move up into the
villages, into the mountains.
I wasn't working deep into the mountains,
but somewhere in the middle.
Now, all the spatial
arrangements are messed up.
And auntie Yona was saying,
next time I come back
I won't be able to
recognize people's houses
because everybody's
living next to each other.
It's very crowded now,
this is what I sense.
And the 12 step thing is so
accurate, that's so great.
Thank you.
Yes. A lot of the men
were alcohol drinkers
and in that sense, there's
the haunting there as well
because they're haunted
by (mumbles) higher.
And so there's a very strong kind of,
"We're going to reject
the alcohol drinkers."
But most of the villagers
were alcohol drinkers,
and it's only in the last 20 years,
that this Christianity has picked up
in this particular village.
- [Eric] Thanks, Ting.
While we're on this topic,
there's two brief statements
or questions in the chat
from Larry Hashman and
Jared Bakeman or Bikeman,
I'm not sure how to pronounce it,
but can you read those yourself
or would you like them to read it or?
- [Ting] I can read it.
- [Eric] Okay.
- Larry is asking about
whether the men were
surprised I was a woman
and interested in their drinking.
There were alcohol drinking
women in the village.
A couple of uncle Mobi's wife
was kind of a lapsing Christian.
And uncle Yosa's wife was not a Christian
until uncle Yosa eventually
converted to Christianity,
and then she followed him.
So women drinkers are not unheard of.
I felt that they were
not so much surprised.
And I think I wasn't actually,
it was kind of organic.
I didn't really start
it off very interested.
I think I started off very annoyed
because I was like, "Oh,
why do I have to stay up
"and listen to you drinking?"
But then I think it took some time
for me to to listen with auntie Yona.
She's always so generous and patient.
And then I think it was
very much a spectacle.
So it was very much kind
of, "I want you to see this.
"I want you to take pictures of me."
And even got a bit angry
when sometimes I was so tired.
I didn't wanna take pictures anymore.
And so I think maybe not so much.
Yeah. Maybe I think they
were not so much surprised
as wanting to be heard.
I think it was surprising for them
that I wanted to learn Lisu language
because it's always considered...
I mean, why would you study
Lisu, it's so useless,
by the Chinese government's
kind of propaganda,
but actually many of these
non-Christian Lisu men
were not as surprised as the Christians
about why I wanted to learn Lisu.
For them it was, "We have a lot of skills.
"We have a lot of knowledge.
"Why wouldn't you want to learn from us?
"It's so strange that my kids
don't want to learn from me."
And so I think maybe they are surprised
that younger generation people
are not taking them more seriously.
Does that answer the question?
- [Eric] Sorry.
I accidentally pressed the
mute button on you Ting.
So I didn't mean to do that,
I was meaning to press my own
mute button, unmute myself
but there was a quick question from Jared
and then there's a hand
up from William Julian.
So if you could just go in that order.
You'll have to unmute yourself
because I accidentally
pressed your mute button.
It's not your fault, it's my fault.
- [Ting] Thanks. No.
My fault here, I didn't notice.
Yeah. The meat prohibition
is really interesting.
Ethnographically, the idea is that
Christians are not allowed
to eat the meat of non-Christians
because it will make them sick,
that it's kind of a betrayal of a promise
that you made to God and
that you will be punished.
And there were stories about men who...
The ones that I'm thinking of all men.
The alcohol drinking men who
converted to Christianity,
but then ate the meat
of a non-Christian
died of some tummy problem,
he couldn't stop going to the bathroom.
And another one wasn't to
do with Christianity so much
and non Christianity.
There was a Christian who ate the meat
of a wild animal.
And actually it might not
even to do with the...
I'm not so sure if the
person was Christian,
but the Lisu person ate
the meat of a wild animal,
a big wild animal.
and wild animals are supposed
to have spirits in them
and that spirit eventually
killed Lisu person.
So there are the stories about meat
that can be eaten and cannot be eaten
along the lines of Christian
and along the lines of Lisu
verses the spirits as well.
I think it's something to do...
My instinct is to think
that it's something to
do with reciprocity.
because one of the stories
is that Lisu actually have
an agreement with the spirits
to always be giving meat to the spirits.
If the Lisu stops providing
meat to the spirits,
then the Lisu person will fall ill.
But it's been many, many years
since Christians provide
meat to the spirits.
And so perhaps it's something
about allegiances and betrayal
and the punishments for not
meeting those reciprocal ties.
I'm sorry. Does that answer a little bit?
I think this is something
that I'm also working on
and trying to make sense of too.
- [Eric] No, that was a great reply Ting.
I wanted to...
I'm mindful of the time everybody.
Although Ting said that sometimes
she doesn't like staying up
taking pictures of people,
I should remind everyone
that it's 1:00am over there
in Singapore where she's dialing in.
So I wondered if the next to Julian,
I didn't mean to make you disappear,
but sorry.
I was gonna say that Julian and Tweak
had asked their questions at once,
but that may have made Julian disappear.
I didn't mean it in that way,
but anyhow, Tweak, can
you ask the last question
before we say goodbye?
- Yeah.
It's too late there. Is
10:00 am here. (mumbles)
I listened to you, to your research
and it reminds me about Vietnam.
The Mekong Delta, where I
work is exactly the same
when I first came there from Ho Chi Minh City.
And so (mumbles) the men drinking
and is exactly the same.
So my question is, I have a
lot of question in my head,
but we don't have time.
I just have one question for now.
The women's attitudes,
based on my observation
in the Mekong Delta
20 years ago when the
economic development,
women didn't go outside,
they stay in the village
and then they enjoy the men's drinking.
Sometimes they complain, but they enjoy.
So through drinking men empower
themselves through drinking
and women enjoyed it and
women prepared for them,
but I will encourage them to drinking.
They don't complain, they didn't complain.
But when economically developed,
women went outside for chop income,
they didn't like it anymore.
I'm not sure, that's about
Vietnam, the Mekong Delta.
So I'm not sure what happened there
based in the area where you research.
because you talk about
development in this course
and how that influenced
the women's attitude
and the men's...
Men stayed the same, I
think, in the Mekong Delta,
men still enjoy drinking,
but women they can't
because of development.
That's my question.
I have a lot, but...
- [Ting] Yeah. Thank you.
That's so interesting.
So after development,
they actually stopped
enjoying the men drinking.
It's so interesting. (laughs)
I think where I'm working,
the women in general
if they are Christians,
they generally really perform,
not liking men drinking
but backstage they do drink
kind of like a special occasions
and they have like a special alcohol beer
and then they will, "Okay, secret. Secret.
"Don't tell anybody."
And I take pleasure in that
'cause I actually want
to drink a lot of times,
and so I don't tell people
because I want to continue drinking too.
So, then I think there
was also this incident
that was very interesting
'cause I think, I feel like
auntie Yona was kind of that way
where she really enjoyed
hanging out with men drinking.
And actually there was a period of time.
And so her daughter and
a lot of other women too,
outwardly, they really perform
how they don't let alcohol drinking men,
but then when it comes to hanging out
with alcohol drinking men,
some of them really seem
to be having a lot of fun with the men.
And in fact, when uncle Zoda
stopped drinking for a while,
because he was very shocked
by uncle Mobi's death
and really worried about himself
because the villages often say
that death in the village
I work with come in pairs.
So he was really worried about his life,
and he stopped drinking for a while.
And it was almost as if auntie
Yona was very disappointed.
Auntie Yona and Nana
seemed almost disappointed
that he was no longer drinking.
There's that, I think maybe it's similar,
but I haven't really come across
how women coming back and
they don't like men drinking,
but I feel like a lot
of time women come back
and, in fact, they drink themselves.
So kind of the migration patterns change.
A lot of people become not Christian
after they come back from
migrating in the cities.
Yeah, so interesting.
(laughs) The change of...
- I'd like to kind of
gracefully bring it to close,
but I'm mindful that there's
one last question from Denny
about the experiences with
women while men are drinking.
So if you wanted to say just
a really quick reply to that,
then I'll stop the recording,
and then we can kind
of linger a little bit
if anyone likes to,
but I do wanna bring it to a close
since it's so late over there.
- [Ting] Yeah.
So mostly women, Christian
women are working very hard.
So every day chores,
taking care of the pigs,
going to look for pig food,
looking for a (mumbles)
even managing all the bureaucracy
because Chinese government
often have to fill in forms.
You have to go down to the village brigade
and if you can't write,
you have to find somebody who can write
who can communicate, who can....
Going to fights, and she
had to deal with that.
So uncle was often yeah, just drinking
and she would have to deal with all that.
And so it's very gendered
and very patriarchal.
And when he was drunk he often
would even try to stop her from relaxing.
Yeah, I think that's
something, I think it's...
It is an affliction.
It's not easy for anybody
to be in that space.
I guess at the same time
as trying not to romanticize drinking,
I think it's also important
to hear this other angle,
but I think it is from
the women's perspective
it can be very frustrating.
And from Christian women,
like Auntie Yona's perspective
who has to deal with so much
of the mundane everyday life.
And it's so interesting, it's so gender
that the men tend to take the spectacle,
whereas the women are in
the mundane and the boring.
And I ended up writing
about the spectacle
rather than the mundane.
Yeah, it's very interesting.
Thank you, Danny.
- [Eric] Well, thank you
Ting for a fantastic talk.
I hope everyone can
join me in thanking you
for just this wonderful presentation,
and great Q and A session
as well. (clapping)
- [Ting] Thank you for the chance
and thank you for the great questions.
So helpful for me.
Really helpful.